les abbés l'eau que vous avez découvert
sur la chaîne du cnrs zeste de sciences
bienvenue les a tués docteur docteur pas
d'acteur c'est existe pas tuer docteur
en géophysique
maintenant que tu as dit si tu te
consacrer complètement la vulgarisation
oui tu as été piqué par le virus alors
ça y est c'est fini c'est ça c'est qu'il
moustiques qui t'a piqué à la
vulgarisation qui t'a donné envie
je sais pas c'est
c'est comme ça tu as envie d'en parler
je peux dire 13 tué sa mère à l'homme et
à tanger pas dit ce qu'il moustiques
pour qu'ils disent mais je vois ce
n'était pas une perche tendue
bon tu attends attends attends j'ai un
doute leur oui tu prêt pas partie de la
saison 2 de vortex là aussi messi
abattant avait un teaser pour toi oh là
là à les regarder le teaser de l'aléa
bello dans le vortex saison 2
[Musique]
aujourd'hui environ un tiers des espèces
sont menacées d'extinction et chaque
année environ 1% supplémentaire s'ajoute
à la liste
qui milite pour la sauvegarde des
termites ou des mouches
parlons c'est carrément un biais positif
les solutions durables et compatible
avec les activités humaines existent
t'as vu ça où toi
[Musique]
alors les actus a décidé toi de nous
parler d'un temps très très très
lointain sur la terre mais dans le futur
ouais alors écoute vu qu'il commence à
être tard je te laisse réchauffer
l'atmosphère de la fête de la science
parce qu'on le sait tous et est noté le
parce que c'est important de savoir dans
le futur il va faire chaud a les atouts
aléas
[Musique]
merci axel je vais essayer de faire plus
ou moins rapides parce qu'ils ont déjà
23 heures jeux j'ai quand même passé la
semaine avec la fièvre
à cette heure ci je devrais déjà être
couché depuis deux heures donc vous avez
parlé des temps un peu plus court
j'aimerais bien et dans le futur futur
donc je propose de vous emmener 50
millions d'années dans le futur alors à
l'échelle de la terre c'est pas beaucoup
1 parce que bon il a quand même 4,5
milliards 4,4 milliards d'années donc
bon voilà admettons par exemple qu'elle
est 100 ans en gros nous humains ben on
serait là depuis 4 heures et moi je vous
propose d'aller un an en avant donc
voilà oui parce que en fait pour ceux
qui auraient pas écouté du coup j'ai
fait partie de ces rares personnes qui
ont fait une science très méprisé qui
est la géologie voilà donc j'aime bien
mettre les choses à l'échelle de la
terre et léché des cailloux aussi et
donc je vous propose de partir dans 50
millions d'années et donc dans 50
millions d'années bombail a plus
d'humains sur la terre et voilà bah
imaginons qu'ils aient un groupe d'
alien des aliens sympa qui arrive sur la
terre et alors c'est une race un peu
spécial d'alien ils sont géologue
il adore s'intéresser au passé de la
terre et enfin j'ai quand même écrit ça
avec la fièvre voilà donc un peu
d'imagination mais voilà des aliens
géologue qui arriverait sur la terre est
la question c'est est ce qu'il voit
quelque chose qui des indices qui
peuvent leur faire penser que ya
cinquante mille ans il ya eu une
une génération d'humains qui est enfin
plusieurs générations d'humains qui sont
passés sur la terre alors la première
idée donc ils commencent à creuser ils
descendent à la bonne stratégie va dire
au bon endroit
ma première idée ça a été de dire bon
ils vont trouver des fossiles
ils sont vachement chanceux alors ok il
se trouve que j'ai lu un article qui
parle qui étudie comment l'homme a
façonné le poulet pour en faire en
poulet avec un squelette qui grandit
très vite alors très bien mais ils
disent aussi que il ya quand même le
poulet pèse trois fois plus que
l'ensemble des des oiseaux réunit
l'ensemble des espèces d'oiseaux réuni
pèse trois fois moins que l'ensemble des
espèces de poulet sur terre donc là je
me suis dit il faut que je calcule sa
donc en élèves 65 milliards de poulets
par an on abat 65 milliards de poulets
par an pour manger il ya environ 60
millions d'humains qui meurent sur terre
donc en fait ça veut dire qu'il ya mille
fois plus de carcasses de poulets que
deux squelettes humains
donc en fait la lienne géologues du
futur il ya des chances qu'il tombe sur
un os de poulet plutôt hockey et puis
s'il a de la chance en plus il va
trouver ça dans une décharge pétrifié
avec des restes métallique du lithium
des trucs comme ça
et ben du coup je me suis mis à la place
de cet alien géologues du futur voilà
donc moins aliens géologues du futur
face à ça ben je vais me dire que
la terre il ya 50 millions d'années elle
était peuplée de poulets avec une
technologie avancée alors avec la fière
ça donnait un truc complètement
terrifiant c'était ddb poulet mispoulet
me terminator qui allait manger des
trucs dedans ddd des fast-foods kf
arrache quand tu kiffes ride your hands
ben voilà dans ça vous fait pas peur
mais moi ça m'a fait très peur parce que
j'ai imaginé le bec de poulet qui
cassaient des tibias dans les bols enfin
voila je rappelle que les poulets sont
les descendants des dinosaures donc un
jouet nous montreront leur vraie nature
voilà bref
donc on est bien 50 millions d'années
dans le futur donc je suis un géologue
aliens et en vrai je vais avoir quand
même peu de chances de trouver des
fossiles donc je vais m'intéresser à ce
que la rochelle même à me raconter alors
ben voilà quels sont les les empreintes
géologiques que l'homme a pu laisser et
ben c'est pas évident un donc bah vous
avez peut-être une idée
non j'ai pas le plastique
ouais ouais ouais le plastique alors en
50 millions d'années quand même le
plastique un temps de se dégrader
mais il est possible qu'il en reste au
niveau microscopique donc ça tombe bien
je suis un grand géologue donc j'ai
ramené aussi tout le monde matériel de
géochimie et dont six à du plastique
je le trouverai élevé trouvait aussi
deux indices je vais trouver par exemple
donc des dépôts métalliques j'ai dit à
l'heure des terres rares des choses qui
vont me faire penser à une technologie
mais je vais trouver aussi de la zot
oui parce que l'humain a répondu plein
d'engrais donc je vais trouver des
anomalies en azote
je vais trouver aussi des petites des
petites anomalies sur le carbone en fait
des grosses anomalies
parce qu'en fait en brûlant l'ensemble
des réserves d'hydrocarbures que
qu'il ya sur terre l'humain a en fait
créé fin à éliminer l'ensemble du
carbone d'origine organique et donc on a
un manque par rapport aux autres sources
de carbone et ça je vais pas où je vais
pouvoir le détecter et puis je vais
aussi voir des marqueurs d'une grande
hausse de la température
évidemment voilà il puis bah du coup
peut-être que je trouverai quelque chose
qui m'indique rak e il ya eu un accident
nucléaire mais ça je laisserai les
personnes à table ronde nous indiquer si
50 millions d'années après un accident
nucléaire
on peut encore détecté quelque chose on
verra mais bon voilà donc vous imaginez
que malgré la fièvre 50 millions
d'années c'est pas au hasard que j'ai
choisi ça en fait il se trouve que sur
terre aujourd'hui là il ya 56 millions
d'années entre le palais aux scènes et
les eaux seine on a eu une grosse crise
et on a eu notamment une hausse de
température de presque 8 degrés
accompagnée d'une hausse du co2
atmosphérique et puis d extinction
massive
est ce qu'il y avait une civilisation en
tout cas ce passage-là a duré en fait
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'années
et ça c'est pour ça qu'on peut le
détecter
et c'est là où je veux en venir c'est un
paradoxe finalement de détecter une
civilisation sur terre parce que
justement bain une civilisation qui
durent très longtemps
elle va laisser une empreinte géologique
forte et bien-être
sauf que pour durer aussi longtemps il
faut qu'elle ait une gestion raisonnée
de ses ressources et donc une empreinte
géologique plus faibles sur sa planète
donc voilà donc nous aujourd'hui
humains en tout cas en développant enfin
en consommant de façon totalement
irraisonnée les réserves de la planète
eh bien on va laisser pourrait laisser
une très belle marque une très belle
empreinte sauf que au rythme où ça se
développe un peut-être qu'on va juste
tous mourir avant de laisser aucune
trace
voilà je voulais pas la peau et
l'ambiance mais bon bah du coup moi
géologues du futur aliens en fait il est
assez peu probable que ge introduisent
l'anthropocène comme nouvelle époque
après avoir introduit des tas d'autres
époques qui finissent en scène et qui
dure environ 12 millions d'années et du
coup parce que oui bon l'anthropocène
vous l'avez compris c'est quelque chose
de très médiatique et entrepôts centres
et donc en tant qu aliens je vais avoir
du mal à y penser mais par contre je moi
les abello aliens du futur géologue
je vais probablement introduire une
crise entre au pique nique crise comme
les dialogues les définissent d'habitude
c'est à dire quelque chose qui est liée
à une diminution drastique du des
espèces sur la planète et qui dure très
peu de quelques dizaines de millions
d'années quelques centaines de millions
d'années à quelques années comme la
crise crétacé tertiaire kt qui a décimé
tous les dinosaures
sauf les poulets et donc les vélos
géologue futur aliens
je mélange tout donc la liane géologues
du futur intro durera probablement la
crise anthropique
il y à 50 millions d'années depuis le
futur entre le quaternaire et le b loïc
bien évidemment voilà merci
merci merci beaucoup c'est bon c'est
utile nous a bien plombé l'ambiance un
nom passionnant au qui ouvre en même
temps à la fin à une discussion sur
l'anthropocène et ses grandes
discussions chez les géologues je crois
c'est en plein débat on va pas entrer là
dedans parce que par contre je vais
poser la question puisque tu nous a
renvoyé la question ici s'il y avait un
accès bon je suis désolé noël mais à
chaque fois qu'on parle du nucléaire
font toujours parler de ce qui va pas
des déchets des trucs comme ça mais vous
êtes d'allier à la scène donc vous devez
pouvoir de réponse y avait un accident
nucléaire
est-ce qu'elle trace en restera-t-il
dans 50 millions d'années et ben dans 50
millions d'années pas grand chose en
fait
ll ya dans cette taille et ballon ça a
tout fait péter sicilia plus d'humanité
c'est sûr il y aura des accidents
nucléaires parce qu'il faut quand même
refroidir le combustible qui a dans les
centrales nucléaires donc il y aura plus
personne pour activer pour refroidir
donc là il ya un moment
voilà ça va exploser ça c'est sûr voilà
il va y avoir des petits problèmes mais
50 millions d'années mais en fait les
produits de fission artificielle qui ya
dedans
ben la période de 2010 il y en a pas
tant que ça de 50 millions d'années donc
grosso modo il restera pas grand chose
comme à des activités web bien ouais
c'est ça on le verra pas ça rejoint un
petit peu donc on n'aura pas existé en
quelque sorte d'accord tu nous tiens
j'ai un peu parce que tu soulèves la
discussion autour de l'entrepôt scène
qu'on n'a pas le temps d'aborder ce soir
mais c'est une grande discussion
les géologues majoritairement sont
contre ce concept encore cole dans les
conférences internationales ça commence
à se disputer un petit peu mais c'est
ton avis et cet intérêt sur le web et de
la longueur que dure une époque pour
l'appeler en scène à bray effectivement
mais j'adore l'idée on trouve finalement
une population poulet qui a peuplé et
qui était développer technologiquement
ça c'est quand même assez génial comme
quoi on peut se tromper quand même
en fouillant qu'est ce que vous en
pensez peu de réaction du poulet - oui
oui j'ai j'ai tiqué sur le passage où tu
parles d'une éventuelle civilisations
passées qui aurait pu exister et qui
n'auraient pas laissé de traces comme la
note ne laissera pas de trace donc
quelle est la crédibilité de cette
hypothèse là alors il ya même des
scientifiques parce que qu'ils ont donc
un
il ya un climatologue qui a rencontré un
astrophysicien
ils ont probablement beaucoup regardé
docteur où ils sont décidés de d'écrire
un article sur la possibilité d'une
civilisation syriennes et leurs idées
c'est vraiment ça ils testent cette
hypothèse là est ce que
est ce qu'il aurait pas fallu trouver
d'autres marqueurs et donc les marqueurs
que j'ai cités c'est cela c'est à dire
que pour l'instant on n'a pas trouvé ses
marqueurs la dent dans les couches
géologiques et à 56 millions d'années
donc on peut se dire que il n'y avait
pas de civilisation mais mais ça pouvait
être une civilisation qui avait pas une
technologie ou qui avait pas épuiser la
planète au rythme où on a épuisé
très bien pour conclure les amis parce
qu'il va falloir conclure cette soirée
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter clair
ça eu une future enfin déjà vidéaste
mais de talent alors faut il faut nous
raconter clair vous êtes la gagnante du
concours
ça s'appelle science toute assurance et
un concours interne au cea commissariat
à l'énergie atomique qui a lancé une
idée comme ça allait qui sont les
chercheurs les chercheuses qui veulent
jouer le jeu des vidéastes et qui se
lancent à faire des vidéos pour
expliquer leur domaine de recherche est
bien ça c'est tout à fait ça oui
après c'est quand même un travail
d'équipé pour rendre hommage aux
thésards du labo qui vous avez
parfaitement raison à ce montage vidéo
et l'idée c'était effectivement de faire
passer
l'idée d'un brevet à la base donc
quelque chose d'assez difficile à
expliquer faire passer cela sous forme
ludique est alors un travail alors déjà
le fond du sujet est passionnant pour
l'avenir parce que ça part d'une micro
algues qui produit elle-même vous le
raconte auriez mieux que moi on va pas
rentrer dans le détail mais un
biocarburant naturel tout à fait qui
produit des hydrocarbures qui sont
utilisables comme des carburants et
médéric moment sans transformation sans
raffinage sans transformation un petit
animal on est tout petit un tout petit
microscopiques
donc il va falloir beaucoup quand même
une enfant beaucoup mais le début de la
recherche est quand même passionnant
tout à fait et alors la forme aussi
oui pardon non avec des objectifs de
développement important et intéressant
pour nous ouais
et puis et puis avec une forme très très
amusante aussi vous pouvez aussi passer
beaucoup beaucoup de temps parce que
beaucoup de découpage donc le ccoc
motion vous avez mis combien de temps à
le faire alors en fait pour le tournage
pas très très longtemps parce qu'on
était un peu pressés par le temps
et oui le plus long ça a été les dessins
qui a été fait par par solène et les le
découpage parce qu'il y avait des
découpages assez précis à faire
effectivement après le tournage ça a été
assez rapide et cette vidéo peut la voir
sur le site de sur le youtube du sua sur
le youtube il se bat et le sujet est
réellement passionnant on dénombre on
découvre beaucoup de choses
voilà on va terminer la tuer bravo à
classe a eu à toute son équipe toutes
les clauses côté sur un travail d'équipé
québec merci
[Musique]